[Music]
sing Oh Spirits hearken All
Souls every year on this date we offer a
Clarion called Fester Adams stop it
[Music]
parley
kids from generation to gener
generation are Beacon to the
beyond all close eyes and join
hands ow what a grip ow oh my
hand my hand she's got my
[Music]
hand
a excuse me oh okay pumpkin sit down
join the fun mama you should know
better thing you're a
handful
Wednesday let us Ransom you from the
power of the Grave tonight oh death let
us be your
plague
[Music]
f i feel that he's
near Pastor Adams gather your strength
and knock three
times did you hear that ask again mamama
quickly by all means ask ask Fester
Adams I demand that you'll not
[Music]
again
he's at the
[Music]
door home
cooking there's nothing like it in the
world may I have the
salt what do we
say
now
what is this
m oh
this start with the
eyes did you sleep
well like the Dead really who would have
thought the Bermuda Triangle could
change a man so much used to toss and
turn all night we had to chain you to
the bed post doesn't make
sense the Remuda triangle is a very
strange and mysterious place you'd be
surprised at all the things you don't
know she certainly would Wednesday adors
the Bermuda Triangle she studies it
death at se she's hooked ask me
anything
being in my old room sure brings back
memories remember Camp Custer for pretin
offenders heart memories precious today
I like to wander through the house
remember him no no sorry old man no
wondering today today we're going
straight to the
vault
[Applause]
Bravo
Pugsley but if he's not Uncle fesser
then who is he somebody
else it has to warm up
why so it can kill you I knew
that children what are you doing I'm
going to electrocute him but we're late
for the charity auction but mother I
said no
[Music]
please oh all
right
[Music]
where are you going there trouble hey
not to worry Plan B but That Hideous
little girl know I'm in charge 10
minutes I'll be
[Music]
back
[Applause]
[Music]
St
M Muska mka with
[Music]
Muska I
swear by
mom and
Dam this
detestable festers
the F
Adams so hey hey hey hey hey hey hey
dance brotherly
[Applause]
love
good show old
man Gomez Kia marvelous news I'm going
to have a
baby right
[Music]
now nurse how close are the contractions
every 15 seconds doctor are you in
unbearable pain is it inh human my
darling is it Torture
we and then Mommy kissed Daddy and the
angel told the St and the St flew down
from heaven and left a diamond under a
leaf in the Cabbage Patch and the
diamond turned into a baby our parents
are having a baby too they had
sex push Mrs
Adams forceps
forceps
[Music]
forceps Mrs Adams would you like
anesthesia no thank you but do ask the
[Music]
children this is Adams the
baby it's a boy it's a
girl father what is it it's an
[Music]
Adams
w
[Music]
there
she
[Music]
oh
w
each summer we take this occasion to
celebrate a seminal event in American
history this year we depict perhaps the
most important day in our shared past
the first Thanksgiving a day for Mae the
Native American word for corn a terrific
turkey dinner and Brotherhood so white
meat and dark meat take it away
[Music]
eat us hey it's Thanksgiving Day eat us
we make an nice we lost the race with
farmer head
eat us we're good and dead man or red
from or sou
CH and put them in
your eat me sa barue eat me we pet but
now we're F we won't stay fresh for very
long so us we finish this
song Eat us before weish this s the gods
of My Tribe have spoken they have said
do not trust the
pilgrims especially Sarah Miller Gary
she's changing the words and for all
these reasons I've decided to scalp
you and burn your village to the
[Applause]
ground children C you're destroying my
[Music]
Tex he's not a team player he's a
special child but he needs friends he
needs friends like
[Music]
this
[Applause]
[Music]
uh I beg your
[Applause]
[Music]
pardon
[Applause]
[Music]
a